-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers
and this is "Late Night."
We hope you are all doing well
tonight and, now,
let's get to the news.
California Governor Gavin Newsom
yesterday
defeated a recall attempt
by a nearly 2:1 margin
and Newsom was so relieved,
his hair unclenched.
[ Laughter ]
After former
Vice President Mike Pence
told former President Trump,
during a meeting on January 5th,
that he didn't have the power
to overturn the 2020 election,
Trump reportedly said,
"But wouldn't it be almost cool
to have that power?"
[ Laughter ]
You're asking Mike Pence
what's cool?
[ As Pence ]
Well, yeah, I guess
that would be cool,
but then again,
so is "Godspell."
[ Laughter ]
-According to a new book,
Joint Chiefs of Staff
Chairman General Mark Milley
took steps,
after January's Capitol attack,
to limit former
President Trump's ability
to launch a nuclear strike.
Specifically,
he changed the launch code
to 11112.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new book,
President Biden finds living
at the White House
to be cold and lonely.
Said the decorator,
"Thank you!"
[ Laughter ]
According to a new survey,
more than half of Americans said
that they have never been
in a physical fight.
"But what if someone
slightly inconveniences you?"
asked Boston.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, a man in England
recently claimed
he had a McDonald's sandwich
with a pig nipple in it.
Even more disturbing,
it was a Filet-O-Fish.
[ Laughter ]
Hard to get
more disturbing, but,
Goldich found that extra gear.
[ Laughter ]
That was a monologue, everybody.